it's a business idea that makes most
people react with disbelief Christina
keine makes artificial lenses for pets
babysitter fila flick with the help of
veterinary expertise she developed a
product for animals suffering from
cataracts mostly dogs and cats the
operation costs between a thousand and
fifteen hundred euros money that some
pet owners are happy to part with
already and wonder daily cuts it he's
like a mother needless I say a little
provocatively there's a grandmother and
a dachshund waiting for a cataract
operation and in the United States
people tend to find it easier to decide
in favor of the dachshund because
grandma's going to die anyway we're
market leaders in the u.s. we're very
well established people are far more
prepared to have their pets operated on
than in Europe for example that has too
much been in law / in europe her
business is having difficulty taking off
in asia by contrast demand is high
christina keine employs just over 50
staff it's her fourth startup she's
already sold two at a profit
keine started off making lenses for
people a research chemist by profession
she didn't have much experience in
business her initial startup capital
25,000 German marks I severus been proud
eh was a very difficult time money was
in very short supply but back then i
have to say bankers were rather more
generous i got loans even though i
wasn't turning a profit and you go
people glance at them I'm fine Karnas
company is based in Henning stoff near
Berlin she came to the Eastern German
state of Brandenburg 20 years ago drawn
by the subsidies on offer her as us one
of the first new businesses here the
proximity to the capital was important
to her too she's more likely to meet
investors and events such as the
biotechnology conference vio nada
mark to Canada Mexico
this investor isn't interested kainaz
company has a turnover of 5 million
euros that's too small for him
the glue that agrees and the critical
size is 10 million if you do a lot of
R&D then at some point you can't afford
to fund it yourself and then an investor
can be very helpful and listening this
this initially back at the company a
team meeting is in progress the topic
under discussion IT expenditure it's too
high in qeynos view and she asks for an
explanation no has analyzed enough
usually mom the idea here to file atoms
in snv technologies kinda wants the
staff to feel responsible for the
company by this in the hood but she also
wants them to be able to talk frankly
openness is important to her Vinnie
Dimity battery nenita but if I really
give the staff the feeling they have an
important part to play in determining
the company's success or its failure
then they work harder and it's more fun
to come to work in the morning you can't
work efficiently if you arrive at work
with the gut feeling this stupid company
I can't wait till it's 5pm often
leaflets bad Finn for then this minute
lessons fig Christina keine works 10
hours a day she has no time for hobbies
in her spare time she reads trade
literature to keep abreast with the
latest developments her next product die
for an artificial iris
you